[Music]
[Applause]
uh we asked for Paul feinbaum and Paul
Finebaum delivers ESPN radio host and of
course the Paul feinbaum show the voice
of the SEC live every weekday at 3
Eastern on SEC network and ESPN Radio
back for uh the 10th season of SEC
Nation this fall airing Saturdays at 10
A.M Eastern on SCC network
uh just got word that the Pac-12 is as
we speak Paul they are basically asking
all their members who's in and who's not
with Arizona perhaps out maybe Arizona
State out let's start with the Pac-12
with what you think it's going to
eventually look like
well if you would called me an hour ago
I would have said it was about over for
the Pac-12 but since your show began uh
there there's a sudden change in it so
it's a little bit hard to uh figure out
what they are thinking about right now
since they don't know what they are
doing in my estimation uh I think last
night Arizona was gone uh that seemed to
be all the indicators out of Tucson and
that perhaps meant Arizona state would
join them you had Oregon and Washington
dealing with the Big Ten but at this
moment Dan I hate to you know act like
I'm standing outside the federal
courthouse in Washington uh but at this
moment in time I don't think anybody
knows which way it's going it looks like
the trend lines maybe that the league is
going to be salvaged although I don't
know what
purpose it would be for Arizona or
Arizona State or anyone to stay in that
League they have nothing going for them
they have a ridiculously bad television
offer on the table uh so I would get out
of there but again I'm I'm just a talk
show host I'm not a
University president with all the
knowledge that they have well I don't
know how much knowledge they have
certainly in the Pac-12 with what's gone
on here but why would you stay why would
these schools stay
uh I I think there's a lot of internal
pressure uh you know as you probably
know Dan because you follow college
football unlike a lot of national hosts
um people value Tradition now I don't
know why anyone values tradition
considering that the sport really
doesn't honor it anymore but there's
this feeling among some especially the
president at Arizona state that the
Pac-12 really matters it doesn't uh it's
a without USC the Pac-12 has nothing
going for it uh that's really what this
is about Colorado leaving uh
only mattered because Deion Sanders
without him it wouldn't have uh it
wouldn't have created a a a speck of
Dust in the Wind uh but but UIC leaving
there a year ago was was a body blow and
yeah yeah they have a lot of like nice
schools and they have good quarterbacks
this year but uh they play too late at
night uh there's not much interest and
quite frankly what we have now we have
two super conferences in college
football and then another what I would
call a nice conference in the big 12. uh
and and I don't know where the ACC is I
mean to me one of the most interesting
stories of the week was the fact that
Florida State decided you know what
we're too good for the ACC uh we won out
uh and even today there's another story
out down on that not to be jumping all
over the place that the university in
Tallahassee is looking into private
Equity to try to buy their way out now
how much would it cost for them to leave
120 million dollars they better they
better work on that pretty pretty hard
yeah let me go back to the Pac-12
because I'm wondering if and we saw this
with Virginia and Virginia Tech when
they went into the ACC they had to go
together because of local governments or
this you know State uh state governments
I don't know if there's Arizona Arizona
State are under that I don't know if
Washington Washington State Oregon
Oregon State can they leave without
taking Washington State can they leave
without taking Oregon State yeah I think
I know I know in the Arizona case the
two are part of the same board uh and so
that is really the problem one group of
people decide for both schools I'm not
certain about the other ones in most in
Most states uh the universities have
different Board of Trustees uh so I'm I
I would not Venture a guess on on Oregon
or Washington but there's
I don't know how you can look yourself
in in the eye for the president Arizona
or Arizona State or any of those schools
and want to stay behind then you know I
know I feel like I'm beating a dead
horse but I do that occasionally
um and so you know good for them uh they
they can they can play on Apple TV and
and be streamed and and be ignored by
the rest of mankind because that's
exactly what will happen and they went
from 10 to 12 they added Colorado and
Utah they tried to do 14 they tried to
get Texas and Oklahoma
but then the Big Ten commissioner I
think wouldn't let Texas keep all the
money from the Longhorn Network I mean
imagine if the Pac-12 had those schools
that they could be a real force and it
just feels like a sleep at the wheel
Dan in 2010 as you remember uh Texas was
gone uh they were taking a group of
schools with them to the Pac-12 and and
Texas decided they they were like-minded
of Cal and Stanford they felt like their
academics uh match there that was that
was that was back in the the dark ages
of of of Intercollegiate Athletics when
somebody actually realized that people
go to school and
that almost happened it didn't uh the
Longhorn Network was born uh and that
was really uh what led all these other
schools to leave uh the the Big Twelve
uh I mean there was you know between
Nebraska and Missouri and Colorado uh
all these schools Texas A M uh they all
started leaving because of Texas and and
now here we are and and again it's easy
to beat up on uh one man but I'm going
to do it Larry Scott uh will possibly go
down as the worst commissioner in the
history of Intercollegiate Athletics uh
he had all these things at his hand he
couldn't he couldn't make anything
happen he would his credentials to be
the Pac-12 commissioner 13 years ago was
I think he was the president of the
indoor tennis Association of the world
tennis Association or some something
like that and uh he also turned down a
deal with the mothership about four
years ago which would have kept them
cranking along pretty well right now but
it wasn't good enough for him talking to
Paul feinbaum ESPN radio host the Paul
feinbaum show let me look at what the
Big Ten is doing because
if if you're looking down the road here
Tony batidi is running the Big Ten TV
guy sharp guy and a source said he's a
and he's a good foil with Greg Sankey
like you know those two are going to run
college football here in the next 10
years but if you're the Big Ten what is
your strategy here and how does Florida
State factor into that strategy
well I think I think they need to be
careful and you're right and what's
different about today versus a year or
two ago is that Kevin Warren who was the
commissioner of the Big Ten felt like he
knew everything uh and he did not care
to deal with people like Greg senke uh
Sankey and petiti have already met a
couple of times uh they have they they
are they they realize they are the two
Titans they may have competing interests
but they have to uh you know look after
each other because they are they are
literally at the epicenter of the sport
and I I don't think Florida State's
really where the uh Big Ten it wants to
go I think the big big ten to always
covered Notre Dame but but Dan that
story has been going on for about 50 or
100 years
um I think they're they're watching the
ACC pretty closely because that's
another League that is a powder keg uh
and I I'm not suggesting it would it
could blow up but if enough schools in
the ACC say we don't we want out uh
there's there's a poison pill in and
there's in in their structure that could
create mass mass chaos other than what I
mentioned was 120 million dollar exit
fee I I think schools like North
Carolina Virginia they're much better
fits for the Big Ten than Oregon and
Washington and quite frankly I don't
think Southern Cal uh when they made the
move really uh wanted anybody else from
the from the Pac-12 invited other than
UCLA yeah it's a great point I was told
that yesterday that that was part of the
agreement whether it was written or not
but you know saying to USC we're not
taking anybody else from the Pac-12
it'll be you and UCLA
um
SEC adding any schools I mean they have
to they have to knock on your door you
can't show up without an invitation here
but can you see that
yeah I I can see that only if uh the Big
Ten
moves on and grabs somebody uh the SEC
you know is like everyone else these are
these are difficult things to do to
digest two new schools the SEC is still
struggling whether it wants to play
eight or nine games when it when the
expansion comes next year I I think
they'll wait it out uh but clearly
Florida state was talking to the SEC uh
on on Tuesday they weren't talking to
the Big Ten and if Florida State figures
out a way then there's Clemson and and
Dan Clemson and Florida State feel and
feel like SEC schools yes they are SEC
schools but Florida would be okay with
Florida state in the SEC
uh probably not but I doubt they really
get a vote uh Texas A M didn't want
Texas uh but the league wanted them I
mean this is no longer a democracy uh
one man rules the SEC if I gave you
Georgia or the field
who you taking
I I still like Georgia Dan uh there they
have the easiest schedule known to
mankind other other than maybe
Michigan's
um except uh they don't have to play
Ohio State uh they play uh Tennessee uh
as their toughest Game of the Year and
that game is uh on on the road but it's
still it's still not as tough as Ohio
State uh they have everything going uh
this this Georgia team looks like
Alabama did 10 years ago when they were
trying to 3p which is exactly what
Georgia is attempting to do and I think
they will
has Nick Saban won his last title
I think there's I I I think he has one
more in him
um I I think he has enough Talent on
that team uh to win another title uh
they simply have to figure out the
quarterback position and that is a
mystery uh one day in the practice
great to talk to you thank you Paul have
a great weekend
down a pleasure thank you Paul feinbaum
voice of the SEC